Alto Kurume organization The main activity is to give all gourmet restaurants in the world a maximum rating of 3 stars and
publish the results as a book once a year.
A person's status soars On the contrary, he lost his confidence while making huge profits and
lost his
grip.
The person
who wrote the evaluation
is called the book today, and the working members who are active on the site
are waiting for the good taste of Lookman.  Wego If it says "
Restaurant Yukihira" on the
clothes,
it's
not a
restaurant unless it's on the book.  There are a lot of people who
say That may be true But what is it?
[
Applause] No
[music]
I made
a fool of him.  It has nothing to do with Sara.
The other side
Please make a good plate today
I thought you were just a bossy person but you said nice things It's
interesting